[Music]
in poop knife news submitted by Julia
chow but that isn't I was like EW look
on ants YouTube channel I don't know
where else go with that I was like what
I have an image of Julie eating a
chocolate popsicle like that cynical no
it was like those fruit popsicles oh
okay well anyway knives made of frozen
feces don't make the cut disproving
well-known legend
yeah nice knives made of frozen Fifi's
that's why I was thinking cuz knives
Chau that's what the joke was a knives
chop on the way it's a different but
yeah so apparently there is a kind of
urban legend that an elderly Inuit man
in the 1950s fashioned a knife out of
his own frozen feces and vanished into
the Arctic I guess according to the
story his family took away all of his
tools to try and get him to come out of
the you know frozen wilderness and like
be civilized and like normal society
with everyone and instead he made a
knife out of his own feces and made it
like freeze by spitting on it and then
he according to this article killed a
dog and then used the like the hide of
the dog and the bones to like fashioned
a harness for other dogs and then he
liked to like do a dog sled thing and
then disappeared off into the Arctic
wilderness what that's the legend so
then at Kent State University there's an
anthropologist anthropologist named Wade
Davis and so he was like oh you know I
would test that out so he made it he
made a poop night this is my boot right
have you gonna do it
that way what that is the poop knife can
you out the brightness sorry you know I
don't know what I'm doing so that's
that's the poop knife
so he made a poop knife and spoiler
alert it didn't work so he imagined it
being crumbly in one so it was I don't
know if you call it crumbly but it
specifically said that um he crumbled
diet he said that it melted upon contact
and it just left streaks that he was
trying to cut that's how I killed the
dog yeah you know what I feel like it oh
it will probably only work when it's in
really cold weather
yeah I'm called BS on this guy because
like the conditions aren't said we don't
know if his nutrition was right we don't
know we don't know if his so that's
another thing that they brought up they
brought up um that it was a different
that it could have been a different
market regime yeah it was tougher than I
thought having that much protein with so
many phases exclusive that would help
solidify your fecal matter did he have a
fibrous intake of things was he eating
fur cuz I know my dog eats a lot of her
furs comes out of his poop eating I
don't know he does weird things but they
did say that it was able to cut the
subcutaneous fat okay on the underside
of the hide but the knife-edge still
knows it quickly and became unusable but
did he do it in cold weather started
that way Oh
cutting it down in a room of the
temperature about ten degrees Celsius in
50 degrees Fahrenheit and therefore
future experience might examine coal the
contracts then you get like Canadian
cold or something like that I don't know
I don't know when the exact like time
period of the original spirit took place
or one how cold that was its anyway it
would be yeah why don't you imagine that
if you're holding in your hand though
that that would warm it up anyway and
start to melt in your hand
on how many insulation layers you got I
guess so you can't feel your hands
exactly he lives out already in the snow
his temperatures are you probably weigh
less than everybody else and then on top
of that - how do we know he only used
one knife all right what if you go
fastening a bunch I'm here an entire
life I'm picturing this dude's like
legitimately in the forest and he's like
straight-up Naruto running through some
he sees it pulls out a dagger like
throws it at another one he's still he's
job is he's got sure he can of poop nice
yeah exactly anyway at the end he does
like a quick like seal knives together
he's a super night and that's what he
uses to see so but and we know you want
to use a sword Ryan because because then
that just makes leverage too hard all
right you gotta have like the blade
probably around like you know I'm kind
of thinking like what if the poop is
just a texture and design for the knife
because I feel like you can make an ice
blade yeah but III don't know how many
things you can cut with a nice knife
because I think people have tried that
before because there's no that but you
can't really get there's a legend of
like of like um like an assassin making
an ice pick
like with an ice and then stabbing
someone and then breaking it off and
then leaving and then they bleed out and
you can't tell yeah blades though his
blades is all about technique because
you could take a sharp point push on
something but then it just pushes the
skin down but if you do add a slicing
angle while applying certain like angles
that hey that's how you actually get a
cut yeah but I don't know that the the
edge like stays consistent enough
because like that's why metal makes such
good knives is because that like little
micro serrated edge that is along the
edge of the blade is the other my next
JK party video we're gonna make the
challenge you got to make a poop knife
and you got to stab someone with it and
break the skin let's do it show night
fight to the day where our team names
put them in the comments down below like
comment subscribe by the kishi on Amazon
good bye out there Antoine bandits have
historical context though not in that
you should be able to actually yeah nice
but back in ancient times when people
you know we're fighting with swords and
you know arrows like that they would
they would literally put fecal matter on
it so that when you hit with it you pull
it out you're still going to kick him
you do want to use that for that to kill
somebody in the entire army just
[ __ ] in a bucket and there's like
[Laughter]
yeah put that in one of the things like
cuz they dig pretty gross you would
think they would have that in context
for like the realistic weird weird
fine it's fine but poop jokes no no no
didn't have time between riding all the
lower about the different incestuous
children and what happens with that
needed an expanded season six they
probably could have put in poop jokes
there you go so we got denied poop
knives which you know that actually
probably could have stopped the walkers
before they even got dragon
what did that's what dragon class really
would all is just like crap in one area
and one two mountain and that makes
sense because you know because their
bodies are I would think worn because
they breathe fire so once you're
slinging in them it just dissolves the
[ __ ] and then they [ __ ] you said when
they stabbed blew the hides with the
poop knives it melts it whatever you
stab a walker with a dragon feudal I can
see you delivering all of this with a
completely serious like straight like
nerd rage face like no this is what
happened this is actually what hazard
y-you like they all died like I telling
you people like that I don't know why
anyone believe like for those the other
thing like medieval times didn't they
also do like the thing where they've
like hooked cows like like rotting cows
over restaurant you know what's funny
about that restaurant um so when I was a
kid at camp when we went there it's
completely dinner from the adult version
so when you realize a kid and like
someone like like put you down and like
start to stab you know like no no no no
draw blood drawn in this tournament and
we're like oh we're like me as like
knowing what the real one was like what
no bloodshed as an adult it was like it
was like yeah bloodshed [ __ ] - that
guy you know rip his head off take his
intestines I was like but not real but
you know I said do they like look at the
on the fourth wall be like no good
no bloodshed Kitty's like it's like if
you like G or like knock somebody off
the horse oh I know you're just going
off on your like DQ'd [ __ ] like what are
you talking about like I thought that
was always like I came here for some
murder like they always think we're like
super innocent as children and actually
I'm doing that now too cuz I'm writing
my novel and I'm like I realized I'm
doing that same [ __ ] like can kids
handle this and I'm like that's one shut
the [ __ ] up kids handle anything right
now wait Oh what nama saya I'm sorry I
use like we understood yeah young adult
young adult you sit together like a poop
babe I'm like it's okay to have this
blip yes it's okay to have [ __ ]
blades okay
good see blood that's what yeah
ridiculous yeah I mean dude parents are
bringing their kids to like read our
movies I hate that though I saw so many
kids at Jabbar yo wallet years stop
[ __ ] doing that with your kids you
ruin it for everybody else and your kid
I can almost go under person guarantee
doesn't enjoy the movie yeah cuz they're
[ __ ] throughout the entire [ __ ]
movie that were like they do not bring
your kids here there is no Batman even
technically given that's weird because
even it that the fact that you know gets
blow at the end but even before that
like I don't see how kid were like it's
very even as an adult it was a really
uncomfortable yeah it's not a movie that
I would take my kids to like I feel like
there are fun reading our movies yeah I
can kind of maybe you understand
Deadpool even that bad - that's so
cartoonish and it's milage oh good
that's also why they released the pg-13
Christmas version right right right it's
far marketing but you mean like I was at
the Kill Bill seen the the crazy it
seemed like that was so caught -
initially like that's not how blood
works ever get Joker's yeah that's right
yeah I was gonna say Joker is very like
realistic yeah ready and like it makes
you because the movie is built to make
you feel gross and uncomfy make a video
about Joker talking about that [ __ ] I
can't I can't talk about that [ __ ]
[Music]